ça fait partie de mes nouvelles passions
le cyclisme et puis d'un imperméable et
voilà alors qu'est ce que nous faisons
que jamais alors ben je vous rester dans
la course
si je peux dire puisque cette
circonstance j'ai un nouveau titre qui
est arrivé un tout petit peu plus d'une
semaine qui s'intitule pas la gay - qui
réalisé par djimrabaye oscars au chaud
et qui est voilà je pense que je
commence à me mettre bien en train bien
en rôdant dans la course 2 des vacances
2018 alors balagué moi je dis ça à
baguer mois alors pas la gué moi c'est
une nouveau la sécurité pour moi puisque
c'est du zouk
c'est du combat je veux dire c'est du
compas
guyane donc pour être dans la tendance
mais pas seulement
c'est surtout mon faire danser les gens
et voir regarder tout le monde s'amusait
et se distraire joyeusement peu importe
la compagnie porte-monnaie mais la joie
dans la danse et le chant sur mon
interprétation qui même si c'est une
petite histoire un petit peu
tristounette ça mais quand même du
bonheur
écoute c'est souvent ce qu'on pose comme
question alors voir répondre je dirai
simplement être sincère dans ce qu'on
chante pour que tout le monde puisse se
sentir concerné et et voilà donc oui la
sincérité dans ce que je chante c'est
pour ça que je perdrais le coût est
merveilleusement ce que je fais